so there's a segment from the sean
hannity fox news program from the other
day that was meant to prop up this idea
of
joe biden's not with it joe biden's
having a cognitive issue joe biden can't
think joe biden's brain
is imminently going to fall out of his
head or whatever the case may be and
the clip is just stunning for its lack
of
even like any self-awareness about the
fact that there were real questions
about
donald trump's cognitive struggles
throughout his presidency so let's look
at the first clip to begin with this is
sean hannity and kaylee mcinanny saying
can you even
imagine if there were questions about
for example
trump's cognitive state and it's like
there were
do you not remember kaylee look at this
can you imagine kaylee if
this was donald trump's record or donald
trump was struggling cognitively like
this what would it be like
i can't imagine i i mean look i i was at
the podium when
i was asked over and over again about
his trips to walter reed and they were
routine visits that he took
but they were convinced something
sinister something must have been wrong
with the president he must have been
covering something up
okay so do you guys remember the fact
that donald trump was
constantly acting bizarrely and there
were never any explanations
given and none of it made any sense like
these folks seem to have missed trump's
entire presidency
uh just a couple of examples i mean just
just as a reminder look at a few things
hear trump not only referring to the
1917 pandemic which didn't exist it was
1918
but says that it ended the second world
war which was of course more than a
decade later
in 1917 they say right the
the great the great pandemic certainly
was a terrible thing where they lost
anywhere from 50 to 100 million people
probably ended the second world war all
the soldiers were sick uh
it was a that was a terrible i guess he
meant
the first world war and 1918
which it's not actually true that the
1918 flu
ended the just completely confused and
think
if joe biden said that what would you be
seeing on fox news
trump of course talking about the
oranges
the citrus fruit of an investigation
really wanting to get down to the rind
of
things we could say and looking confused
realizing my
my brain's not connecting properly with
my mouth here
they now go and take a look at the
oranges are the oranges of the
uh uh investigation the beginnings of
that investigation
that's weird that's weird and never an
explanation
and kaylee pretending like the only real
questions are about
joe biden the endless physical shoulder
spasms
simultaneous to like a mental catch on a
word
constantly happening regularly there
were
people seeking a medical explanation for
this here's just one example of that
and let me begin by wishing you a
beautiful
look do you remember this do you
remember they were trying to take
christmas he sort of covers it
in a way where you don't necessarily
pay more attention to it unless you're
aware of the fact that that happens all
the time
never an explanation for why that
happened regularly there was also this
incident and
i'll just we'll show some video as i
describe it
there's this strange incident where
donald trump came down
off of air force one and his
vehicle parked right at the bottom of
the steps
and donald trump famously just kind of
wandering off
and having to be brought back his
vehicle is always right there secret
service everybody waiting for him to get
in
and trump just wanders away and people
start wondering what
what is happening here eventually
someone comes up to trump and says yeah
the car is right there the car was right
at the bottom of the stairs
like it always is every single time
and donald trump brought back to that
vehicle
and we're not going to belabor this but
just to remind you guys
ima you know sean hannity and kaylee say
imagine if trump had done the stuff
biden is doing
imagine what right-wing media would have
looked like if biden was doing half the
trump
stuff trump did they did an entire event
about an executive order
and trump left without signing it and
then mike pence sort of like pretended
like the plan all along was to sign it
in private even though they had
a whole desk set up for trump trump to
sign it in public remember this were you
trying to tell the justice department to
grant immunity to michael flynn
were you trying to do that mr president
is that your intention mr president sir
thank you mr president was that your
intention were you trying to tell the
trump just wandering away
and then pence reminding him you kind of
didn't sign the thing that we were here
to sign
and then just two last ones very quickly
trump referring
uh to apple ceo tim cook as tim apple
we appreciate it very much tim apple tim
apple and then also
uh referring to marilyn hewson the ceo
of lockheed as marilyn lockheed
we have some of our great business
leaders and leaders period right behind
me
i may ask marilyn lockheed
the leading yeah woman's business
executive okay so you guys get the point
and so the he
the the real story here is when you see
these segments on fox news where they
say something like
imagine if trump had ever done the
things joe biden has done
and then you look at what joe biden's
done and it's like oh yeah joe biden has
a stutter
and he's nearly 80 and he's clearly
slowed down from like when he
ran circles around paul ryan however
many years ago it was
they said trump never had anything like
this no no no no it's quite the opposite
and in fact she and hannity and
everybody else was running interference
all along when that was the case just
pathetic hypocrisy and double standards
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com slash pacman
i've been using privacy for a little
over a year now you've heard me talk
about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number
the privacy app and the browser plug-in
let you give each company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create
out of thin air it'll even autofill the
card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information
so this allows you to keep your banking
information secure but also to take
control of your finances you can create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be
charged when the trial is over if i use
a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private by
not telling companies
who you are you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against data
breaches and identity
theft and it's free and like i said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up at
privacy.com pacman